just two hours ago Allied airforces
began an attack on military targets in
Iraq and Kuwait these attacks continued
as I speak ground forces are not engaged
this conflict started August 2nd when
the dictator of Iraq invaded a small and
helpless neighbor Kuwait a member of the
Arab League and a member of the United
Nations was crushed its people
brutalized 5 months ago Saddam Hussein
started this cruel war against Kuwait
tonight the battle has been joined for
most George Garcinia will be best
remembered for this America's first war
against Saddam Hussein far more decisive
and successful than the second his son
would wage a little over a decade later
we're not walking away until our mission
is done until the invader is out of
Kuwait and that may well be for you come
in
[Applause]
its mission was accomplished in just six
months and George Herbert Walker Bush
was welcomed in Kuwait as its Liberator
but to Americans he was much more than a
wartime leader a man whose whole life
seemed dominated by a sense of duty to
country and to party he was born in
Massachusetts the son of a senator
raised in America's ruling class white
anglo-saxon Protestant he was on his way
to Yale College when Japan bombed Pearl
Harbor and he enlisted aged just 18
Americans youngest pilot in the war shot
down by enemy gunfire in 1944 rescued
here after hours in the Pacific
from war hero he became a self-made
millionaire setting up his own oil
company after the war and striking it
rich in Texas before beginning his move
into politics but generally speaking of
flooding the market of flooding the
betting supply and demand Bush's
impeccable wasp credentials wartime
service and money propelled him through
two terms in Congress and jobs as USM
voice of China and director of the CIA
in the 70s in a 1980 election that saw
Ronald Reagan beat Jimmy Carter to the
White House
he chose George Bush as his running mate
for two terms in office they
complemented each other perfectly
Reagan supplying the charisma of a
former actor Bush the competence of a
technocrat
the ninety 88 bush became the first vice
president to reach the White House in
150 years accepting his party's
nomination in a speech including this
famous promise on taxes read my lips
it was a pledge he'd later break but for
much of his presidency attention was
focused abroad as President Bush steer
America through the turbulence of a new
post Cold War World Order managing
relations with Mikhail Gorbachev Russia
a maintaining the special relationship
with Britain cultivated so devotedly by
Ronald Reagan and Margaret Thatcher ties
that were proven valuable during the
biggest test of Bush's presidency Saddam
Hussein's invasion of Kuwait in a
conflict that followed the world saw a
new kind of warfare fought with new
claims about precision bombing and
surgical strikes keeping casualties low
on the coalition side at least I know
what I've got to do I've got very good
people helping me do it
I really don't lose sleep I can't tell
ya I don't shed it here for four
families of and and and for those that
might be lost in in combat we've had
very few losses and yet I gotta tell you
I feel each one but we're gonna continue
this and we're gonna prevail if America
was grateful for George Bush's
leadership it didn't show it in the
elections that followed he proved no
match for the more youthful more
charismatic Bill Clinton I don't want
you to read my lips and I sure did read
is I just do hope you will read our
plans Bush retired from politics
emerging occasionally for skydiving
feats with his sons and helping support
his eldest George W Bush in his
political ambitions
the two proved very different presidents
one quietly spoken but effective and
skillful the other Brasher and louder
leaving a far more questionable legacy
Dominic Waghorn Sky News